Euh je faisais euh je cherchais des des
choses à à
discussion en vidéo puis je me suis
arrêté au
comment Claud C en ce moment
comment que en ce moment Claud C il
prend tout le le du marché tout le monde
parle de CL tout le monde parle de
c'est quoi comment c'est révolutionnaire
Mais qu'il y a pas beaucoup de monde qui
parle vraiment de comment l'utiliser,
comment l'utiliser pour que ça soit le
plus optimal possible. Puis je me suis
fait une petite liste de choses que je
voulais aborder concernant euh Cloud
Code
puis comment l'optimiser. J'étais encore
au début début de Cloud Code mais euh
j'ai écouté énorm énormément de vidéos
là-dessus. J'ai essayé au maximum de
l'améliorer
puis je continue à apprendre dessus.
Mais si euh
tu continues à écrire des notes dessus.
Bon euh bon premier point le second
cerveau fait c'est le contexte que tu
donnes à ton euh à Claude Code.
Cloud C first
utilise est-ce que ça dépend ? Tu
l'utilises
de différentes manières fait qu' a
cloud.ai AI lui que tout le monde
connaît, Cloud Cowork qui commence de
plus en plus à ça parler de lui puis son
CL code
euh Cloud, tu l'utilises plus pour
peut-être pour t'aider à faire des
prompts, faire des recherches, faire euh
moi c'est principal pour ça je l'utilise
Claud de AI des fois des choses qui sont
plus faciles de l'écriture l'écriture de
pause tout ça. Mais même à ça, Claude
COD est meilleur habituellement. Cowork,
je l'utilise plus ou moins. Je te dirais
en ce moment, c'est principalement Claud
code Claud code, la force c'est qu'il
rentre dans ton terminal dans ton ordi,
puis il peut
se connecter à toutes tes documents.
Toutes tes documents, qu'est-ce que ça
fait ? Ça fait qu'il y a un il y a un
contexte qui est le meilleur possible.
Je vous explique. Et par exemple, moi
j'utilise Obsidian. Obsidian
qui est une application qui est open
source que il est sur ton dit. Après ça,
tu peux structurer ton
obsidienne pour avoir toutes tes
documents dedans puis tu peux au final
expliquer toute ta vie, toutes tes
connaissances pour prendre ton cerveau
puis le dupliquer, avoir ton cerveau sur
ton en gros là là c'est expliquer
rapidement là mais c'est ça l'objectif
d'avoir
cloud code
sur ton terminal c'est qu'il y a accès à
toutes tes connaissances. Donc il y a le
meilleur contexte que tu peux avoir.
Puis en fonction de ça, connaissant ça
que tu as le meilleur contexte possible
avec Claude C, c'est de faire un second
cerveau.
Le concept de son cerveau, c'est
de que toutes tes connaissances soient
relié dans une base de données. Puis que
toutes tes connaissances, toutes tes
concepts que tu connais soi interrelié
entre eux.
fait tuas vraiment un cerveau qui est
dupliqué
fait ça te permet après ça de faire un
prompt rapide à Claud en mode je sais
pas moi
quelle pause que je pourrais faire sur
LinkedIn
cette semaine
en lien avec je sais pas moi
la psychologie puis les vent il va aller
voir dans tes dans ton cerveau, il va
aller voir les documents qui sont en
lien avec les ventes, il va aller voir
d'autres documents qui sont en lien avec
la psychologie
puis il va aller voir les liens que la
psychologie est reliée à quoi, les
ventes sont reliés à quoi, qu'est-ce qui
est interrelié
pour faire justement des un réseau de
concept qui s'entremide puis qui crée
des idées qui sont plus complètes puis
avec une nouvelle
approche qui est plus intéressante. fait
que là ça post ils sont mieux sont mieux
recherchés sont plus recherchés donc tu
as plus de valeurs qui sont retirés
làdessus
puis
c'est ça qui fait la valeur de ton cloud
code. Quand tu es rendu à avoir un son
cerveau qui est hyper rempli le contexte
que tu donnes à Claude Code est toujours
le meilleur. Puis là quand tu peux
ajouter ça, ajoutant à ton gros cerveau
que Claude Code se auto rééitère,
ce qui veut dire qu'il s'autocorrige et
s'autoaméliore
de fois en foi,
c'est là que tu deviens avoir un une
machine de rigur dans ton ordi. C'est là
que tu commences à avoir une machine, un
I qui a un meilleur contexte que tu
ajoutes à tous les jours du contexte
parce que tu échanges avec lui à tous
les jours. Il prend des notes ce que tu
lui dis. Il prend des notes sur comment
tu le corriges, comment tu parles,
comment tu écris tes posts, comment tu
euh c'est quoi ta ton quotidien. Il
apprend de plus en plus. Puis il y a des
loops de réération
continue.
Tu ça devient fou parce que là toutes
les tu pas juste additionner des des
connaissances, tu multiplies tu
multiplies des connaissances entre
elles. Il fait de plus en plus de liens,
il apprend de plus en plus.
C'est là que ça commence à être fourel.
Pu c'est que tu vois le potentiel de
cloud code.
Euh donc ça c'est pour
les deux premiers points que je l'
abordé. Donc avoir un second cerveau
puis l'autoéitération.
L'autre point que je l' abordé c'était
le reverse engineering.
Ça c'est quoi ? C'est dans le fond il y
a peut-être probement différentes
manières de l'aborder mais moi comme je
vois c'est
principalement au niveau de ta vie. tu
visualis c'est où que tu veux être par
exemple dans 30 ans,
tu prends cet objectif là,
tu peux demander à Chat GPT
qui te fasse une belle discussion avec
toi, qui te pose des questions
pour aiguiser ce reverse engineering là.
Fait comment tu te vois dans 30 ans ? Fa
que là avoir plein de questions précises
de comment tu te vois ? Tu habites où ?
Tu es avec qui ? Ta journée de type
ressemble à quoi ? tu te lèves à quelle
heure euh tu fais combien et cetera pour
avoir une idée la plus claire la plus
claire possible de c'est où tu t'en va
c'est où tu te vois dans 30 ans.
Après ça c'est que tu es dans 30 ans.
C'est ça ta ta vision mais là tu recules
ou tu reviens sur tes pas dans 20 ans.
C'est où tu te vois dans 10 ans, c'est
où tu te vois. Puis à chaque fois de
d'écrire c'est quoi tu dois faire pour
te rendre là. C'est quoi tu dois faire
pour te rendre à ton 30 ans dans
objectif ? C'est quoi tu dois faire pour
te rendre à ce 20 ans là qui va te
permettre de te rendre 30 ans ?
Puis ainsi de suite. Je OK, dans 2 ans,
je veux je dois être où ? Dans 1 an, je
dois être où ? Pour reverse au maximum
pour e dans 90 jours, je dois être où ?
Dans 30 jours, je dois être dans une
semaine c'est où que je dois être.
Puis là je avoir le lien avec Cloud
Code, c'est que quand tu connectes ton
Cloud Code avec ton ton reverse
engineering,
Cloud Code connaît où c'est que tu t'en
vas dans le futur
puis il peut te guider à prendre des
décisions, à écrire tes posts, à si tuas
des questions en lien avec euh tes
choix, peu importe, mais il peut te
guider parce qu'il sait où c'est que tu
t'en vas.
tandis que c'est une charge pét que il y
a pas de
qui est pas
contextualisé à ce niveau-là, mais il va
te répondre à une question, il va te
répondre une
une réponse qui est vague, qui est pas
en fonction de ton contexte puis où tu
t'envas dans la vie. Puis d'où
l'importance de faire un reverse
engineering avec ton chat GPT et ton CL
code, excusez-moi,
c'est va pouvoir te guider encore mieux
dans toute ta vie. puis tu vas tu vas
comme avoir un accompagnateur de toute
ta vie.
Donc c'est ça que je voulais aborder
aujourd'hui. Donc Claude Code,
c'est la base en 2026.
Si tu veux développer, tu as pas le
choix de l'apprendre.
Surtout c'est peut-être que ça fait peur
un peu qu'un terminal mais tu as pas le
choix.
faire un second cerveau avec obsidian
mettre des processus d'autoréation avec
ton CL code puis
faire ton reverse engineering
faire avec ton chat GPT pour t brain qui
brainstorm avec toi tu copiesoles tout
ce qu'il y a
des questions que tu as posé tes
réponses que tuas donné tu pes tout ça
tu donnes ça à l'autre code puis il va
te les documents dans ton secondau.